c'était il ya presque trois semaines
world kraft le propriétaire milliardaire
des patriots de la nouvelle angleterre
célébrer la victoire au super bowl
sous sa gouverne les patriots ont
remporté six fois le prestigieux trophée
un héros dont la réputation est
maintenant entaché yves mansion jouer
tout seul enfin il est accusé d'avoir
sollicité une prostituée
les faits se seraient déroulés dans ce
salon de massage situé dans le comté de
pro b itx en floride dans le cadre d'une
vaste enquête
24 autres personnes sont soupçonnées
d'avoir été client de ce réseau de
prostitution
deux personnes d'origine chinoise
soupçonné de diriger ce réseau ont déjà
été interpellés par la police
par deux fois l'homme d'affaires de 77
en or et eu des relations sexuelles avec
une prostituée il y environ un mois mais
par voie de communiqué l'équipe des
patriotes nie catégoriquement que robert
kraft ait pris part à une activité
illégale sauf que wintek et jay-z est
danoise pendant sept mois d enquête la
police à documenter tous les actes
commis grâce à une caméra cachée placés
dans les salles de massage permettant
ainsi d'enregistrer les actes sexuels
entre clients et prostituées
robert kraft est un proche de donald
trump celui ci a commenté la situation
de son ami c'est très triste dit il je
suis très surpris au total dans cette
affaire de traite de personnes
plus de 200 mandats d'arrestation ont
été émis et d'autres suivront bientôt
notamment pour blanchiment d'argent soul
kitchen son mari dans son cas et selon
la loi de la floride
l'homme d'affaires originaire de la
banlieue de boston et qui a fait fortune
dans l'emballage et dans l'industrie
papetière pourrait être passible de 60
jours de prison pour avoir sollicité les
services d'une prostituée ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal